hi I'm Izzy Nichols mall and I play
Rachel Hunter I'm Joey Phillips and I
play Denzel Hunter I'm David Berry and I
play Lord John I'm John Bell and I play
Young Ian and I'm Charles vanderer and I
play William Ransom I'm Katrina balf I
play Claire I'm Sophie skeleton I play
Brianna I'm Richard Rankin I think I
play Roger and I'm Sam hewan and I play
Jamie we are the cast of Outlander but
we're actually about to find out who we
really are
thank you
choose a period to travel back in time
to ancient Egypt The Roaring Twenties
the Renaissance prehistoric the wild
west or ancient Greece well I'm going to
choose the Roaring Twenties because I
literally just said that before you did
I'm choosing the Renaissance because I'm
obsessed with Beyonce's artwork yeah I
don't know how long I'd last in a lot of
these like the wild west I've brought
with you Connor I kind of want to do
pick a theme for a party you'd love to
attend old Hollywood Barbie famous
literary characters murder mystery tea
party iconic horror
murder mystery choose a song to sing at
karaoke Mr Brightside by Achilles Truth
Hurts by lizzo Bohemian Rhapsody by
Queen I think we can stop the quiz now
Shake It Off by Taylor Swift Dancing
Queen by Abba and honestly I Crush The
Outlander theme song surely Bohemian
Rhapsody you know yeah
no
[Music]
[Applause]
um which Outlander character would you
trust with the secret Mata marceli John
Gray Jenny William orange
John Gray's done a pretty good job
are we all picking John Gray do the
right thing I love that John Bell isn't
even on here
I was gonna say Rachel Rachel would take
that to her grave yeah Jenny no Jenny
choose an Outlander location to visit
Fraser's Ridge River Run Inverness
uh and then Boston I think Boston I've
always wanted to go yeah all right she
goes to the stones
you could go back to the dinosaur period
yeah
and then seeing Mr Brightside I'm
conflicted guys
and Fraser's rich and like they both
means
all of these places I haven't been to
Boston this is for you Boston
thank you let's go to Boston because
that house is nice
yeah
we're going to Boston yeah
good
which actor would you want to start in a
movie with Viola Davis Keanu Reeves oh
Florence Pew Timothy Charlemagne
do you know I would love to do a film
with Jennifer Coolidge with people to
like do my Impressions
I think come on yeah come on come on
he's gay the train of murder
I'm gonna pick Florence Pew I've got
Keanu Reeves
I'm being so mean to Canada right now
not picking him but a while
I knew I liked you
[Music]
yeah Pedro Davis pick a book to screen
adaptation to watch tonight Pride and
Prejudice Little Women The Hunger Games
I thought that said The Hangover games
now normal people Game of Thrones
you know home team home turf I'm going
normal people as well do you know I
haven't watched Hunger Games in a while
I might do that okay I do love Little
Women because I think it's between that
and normal people I think I'm kind of
hungry at the moment so
um
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go to normal people I haven't
seen it yet but I've heard some parade
have you read it I've not read it and
Charles already pressed the button
[Music]
two one
too I go Brianna I got Ian Murray
um funny that your personality matches
Ian
you're loyal compassionate and cunning
like Ian you marched the beat of Your
Own Drum and don't care what others
think your Fierce loyalty and support
are your strongest qualities and the one
people admire most about you once you
put your mind to Something There Ain't
No Stopping You I mean so cheers
so we got Roger Mack your personality
matches Roger you're curious charismatic
and reliable I agree okay
like Roger you're someone whose
curiosity in the world around you is one
of your strongest qualities your
compassion might be seen as a weakness
to some but it is your greatest strength
and one you should always lean into
and then I got Brianna so your
personality matches Brianna your
inquisitive passionate and ambitious
like Brianna you're someone who loves to
learn your reading is like a bedtime
story
um
you're very passionate when it comes to
things you love most in this world
whether it's your favorite books your
family and more you're always willing to
help those in need very true is there
one that you don't want like is there a
bad age you're a terrible person who are
you I'm Jamie Fraser I'm Jamie Fraser
too I'm Brianna Burgess Jamie
I'm Fergus because my personality
matches Burgess I'm Charming William and
sincere of course and true-hearted like
Fergus you're a person people turn to
and they need someone to stand beside
them no matter what you're someone who
has fought to be where you are and
people look up to you because you're
bravery and spirit was Fergus like that
it is now
okay Jamie Fraser yeah your personality
matches Jamie your strong Brave and
Charming of course like Jamie you're an
alcoholic sorry
you're someone who will do anything to
protect the people closest to you even
if that means charging head first into
any situation you have a big heart and
you often put the needs of others above
your own no it's a nice little picture
of us as well yeah that looks like that
is that all just because you picked tato
I think I think it is a huge Taylor
Swift and he just shakes it off it's an
option to retake I just know what are
you yeah do you want to be Brianna I'm
very happy
it says your personality matches Brianna
inquisitive passionate ambitious blonde
frequently annoying like Brianna you're
someone who loves to learn because she
doesn't know all that much
you just are Jamie I am
remember everyone to tune in to season
seven it's an epic season 16 uh you
shouldn't have relied on me
and remember to tune in to season seven
of Outlander
cheers
[Music]